[Music]
good evening i'm alexander rosen the
executive director here at the long now
foundation as some of you might have
already noticed we have after what was
it now 12 years changed our membership
structure just a little bit we have
changed it so that's new people who sign
up you have to sign up for a twelve
dollar level in order to get the tickets
to events like tonight but all of you
people who have been our great numbers
how long how many people here our
members thank you all of you our
grandfathered in on the old system but
we are asking anyone who can to
voluntarily move to that level so that
we can afford great venues like this one
which as some of you have been in San
Francisco for the last 12 years the
costs have gone up a little bit there's
a little bit so we want to be able to
keep up with that and we appreciate it
if you are able to move to that level it
would be really really helpful for us to
keep doing great things
I am Stewart Brand for the long now
foundation you can tell when I sort of
like a book there's more dog ears here
than pages practically and this book is
out in the lobby so long now foundation
has been looking into us be spending a
couple years looking into what makes
some institutions very long-lived and
one of the first things that emerges is
that companies come and go
cities are basically immortal dynasties
come and go and cities are basically
immortal whole nations come and go and
cities are basically immortal what's
going on well first thing there's really
delved deeply into specks into the
timelessness of cities is our time
traveler an archaeologist Monica Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for the warm welcome
and for the opportunity to be here in
San Francisco one of the great cities of
the Pacific Rim the Gateway to the
Pacific Rim along with of course many
other gateways to the Pacific Rim so
there's Anchorage there's San Diego
there's Tokyo there's Melbourne there's
Sydney there's Hong Kong there's
Honolulu
there's Lima and of course there's Los
Angeles where I come from as well and in
all of those places people celebrate the
places that they're in because cities
offer to us something that you really
can't get anyplace else and when we
think of cities we think about all of
the things that we can find there
including these kinds of entertainment
venues like what we find ourselves in
this evening and of course there are
many other things that make cities
attractive those bright lights that are
part of the big city the opportunities
for exotic cuisine the opportunities for
unique kinds of monumental architecture
the nightlife the kinds of entertainment
that you can only get when you have
those massive city populations places
like sports arenas and other kinds of
venues the opportunity for information
and the opportunity to get just about
any kind of thing you could possibly
want oh yes there's those other things
too but those are the things that we
tend to willingly overlook when we think
about cities and when we have that kind
of love-hate relationship that we have
with people around us we are willing to
overlook the pollution the crowdedness
the high rents of all of the cities that
we know and love and because we get
something out of them that we really
could not imagine in any other scenario
and cities are also not only numerous
but growing there are more than 4,000
cities in the world settlements with
more than one
thousand people each and the number of
cities is growing and the cities
themselves are also getting larger so
there is no such thing as a city that
has stopped growing in fact that's one
of the thing about cities that is
perpetually under construction
perpetually dynamic perpetually under
renovation and growing and some of the
cities that we have in our world today
are enormous but there is no sign
outside of Tokyo that says sorry were
full
there is no sign outside of San
Francisco that says sorry we're full
there is no sign outside of Mexico City
that says sorry we're full and in all of
those places what we have are people who
are coming into cities and living among
strangers if there's anything that's the
hallmark of the giant population centers
that we have in the world today it's the
fact that you are living amongst people
that you probably will never see again
as you pass them on the sidewalk think
about the audience that you're in this
evening how many people do you know in
this room maybe one to a handful maybe
nobody but here you are so with all of
these cities in the world you might
think that they are perhaps the natural
habitat of our species but I can tell
you that nothing is further from the
truth
the earliest cities started only about
6,000 years ago what seems like a long
time but is really just the blink of an
eye in the long history of our species
for the last hundred thousand or more
years we have been the same Homo sapiens
but we have not lived in cities the
things that we had with us as a species
are things that made it possible for us
to eventually combine ourselves into
these giant configurations so what are
the building blocks of urbanism what is
it that we had in the long make
of our species that made it possible for
us to live willingly among strangers to
do very illogical things like be away
from our food supply where is your next
meal coming from you don't really know
but you trust that it will be there when
you want it where does the restaurant
get its food you don't know and you
don't care that is one of the things
that urbanism has flipped the switch on
that makes it both illogical and amazing
the building blocks of urbanism are
things that started many many tens of
thousands of years ago one of them in
particular is language the possibility
of speaking not only to communicate
information but also to think about
things that are not there like the past
in the future both of which are entirely
imaginary constructs but for which we
have the language to be able to envision
something that is not there even more
important is the opportunity to put in a
conditional tense not just a past
present in a future but on what yes if
we build it they will come that kind of
planning is something was absolutely
essential not only to our long human
survival but to the eventual possibility
of living in larger and larger
configurations of strangers another
thing that humans are very good about is
dealing with objects we're the only
species that has stuff and certainly has
so much stuff and we have been trying to
invent new things since the very
beginning the first artifacts of any
detailed aesthetic consequence were from
about a million and a half years ago and
those artifacts were made in quantities
that suggested that mere utility was not
enough as part of the human
composition of making the world around
them of making tools for example the
first artifacts were things called hand
axes and they look a little bit like the
two palms of your hand put together and
we'd have a hard time making one even
today with our sophisticated technical
skills because it requires a certain
amount of imagination to turn a stone
over and over again and manufacture them
without hurting yourself and the amount
of work that goes into these objects is
far beyond what would be required to
make a useful sharp edged tool in fact
there's been some interesting thought
about the way that people manufactured
those hand axes not only to be something
useful but to be a kind of social
calling card hey baby look at my hand
axe another thing that's really
important for humans and that has been
part of our makeup for a long time has
been migration so more than a million
years ago our ancestors walked out of
Africa and into every corner of the old
world that process of walking is still
there migration is not a new phenomenon
it's a human phenomenon and the last
thing that humans do that became a
precursor for the kinds of things we
needed to become urban is the
development of architecture of not just
accepting the world as it is of being
able to find a shelter under a tree or
in a cave but to actually make
structures that suit people not only for
shelter but also as a kind of social
calling card as a way of putting
together a household and making it
visible to the rest of the people around
so those are the things that are the
kind of building blocks of what it took
to be able to be urban but many of those
things were done for tens of thousands
of years before people actually became
an urban species and the first move
towards getting people into larger and
larger
your groups was probably something that
was a ritual impetus the idea of coming
together and gathering with a bunch of
strangers
with something that is evident in the
earliest physical ritual structures that
we have in the world today so you see
here Stonehenge which of course is very
familiar to us and very picturesque and
evocative and then you also have gobekli
tepe which is probably the world's
earliest ritual structure in Turkey made
by hunter-gatherers who were coming
together and constructing these upright
stone circles over and over again to be
able to make a place for people to come
together and have a ritual and we know
archaeologically that these are places
where people came repeatedly over and
over again they came they had
celebrations they had fires they did
cooking they interred their dead and all
of that was very exciting including
probably also people coming along with
trinkets to sell or also you know people
coming along for a little romance you
know down in the village where there
were only 50 or 60 people at any given
time marriage prospects were probably
rather limited so the idea of going to a
ritual event you know with something
like a festival atmosphere so that you
could have a little shopping a little
ritual a little romance all at the same
time but there was kind of a catch about
these ritual centers and that is that
after you were done with the ritual you
were supposed to go home so when we
think about places like Stonehenge we
think about places like gobekli tepe
there are still no cities anywhere near
them so it took something more in order
to be able to get people to live in a
place that was kind of like a permanent
festival atmosphere and once that
started once you had a kind of economy
of people living together of all kinds
of new opportunities for romance for
education for men
that's when the first cities got going
in order to find out about those cities
archaeologically what we can do is
examine the archaeological record to see
what it is that we find from those very
first cities 6,000 years ago but
speaking is an archeologist I can tell
you that that process is not so easy the
investigation of ancient Mesopotamian
cities of ancient Egyptian cities
something that has gone on for the last
two or three hundred years and many
times cities are incredibly obvious in
the landscape so here you see a fanciful
engraving on the rediscovery of the city
of ore and the giant ziggurat that is
there and so even though you might think
of archaeology is something where we
always have to dig that's not
necessarily the case many of those
ancient cities never went away and
they're still right there where our
ancestors left them but when we do dig
what we find is that that constant
layering of time results in an obscurity
of the very beginnings of those oldest
cities and so trying to ask the question
what happened here first is actually
very difficult for archaeologists
because we have to dig through these
layers and layers of archaeological
habitation and if you can imagine being
an archaeologist in a city the size of
San Francisco or even downtown San
Francisco you can imagine that doing an
excavation of an area which might be you
know half the size of this room or the
size of an of an Olympic swimming pool
that would take your team an entire
season to excavate you can see that what
we actually know about ancient cities is
really rather limited it's limited by
the area that we can excavate but it's
also limited by that great depth that
goes all the way down to the bottom
where the very beginnings of
would lie however we persist and in our
excavations what we try to do is we try
to evaluate what it would have been like
to be in a living City whether or not we
have historical documents that can also
shed some light on that process or
whether or not we have other cities
nearby that are potentially linked that
as we work on one urban settlement such
as the Indian side of Chicago where I've
been working with my colleagues for a
number of years as you can see here in
these images or whether we are working
in other places out in the hinterlands
to try to understand how these urban
centers pull together their vast
networks because even in ancient times
cities were always networks there's no
such thing as a single city that popped
up in the middle of nowhere and was all
by its lonesome for a long time
cities always were in necklaces of other
cities just like we think about the
Pacific Rim being all of these
interconnected urban settlements in
which the urbanism really supersedes the
national and state boundaries in which
these globalized cities find themselves
even when we excavate and even when we
expose the architecture of the uppermost
levels for people to see it can still
result in a certain puzzlement about
exactly how these things come together
so if you visited Rome for example or if
you visited Pompeii which is the image
that you see here you can feel rather
bad that you're walking around all of
these ancient constructions and you feel
a little confused like you feel bad that
maybe you should have read the guidebook
better or you should have listened to
the guide more who was going on and on
it's very hot so you haven't been able
to throw don't feel bad
archaeologists are also confused
because all of those layers of
habitation were the result of people
actively modifying their city as they
were living in it they're exactly the
same way that we do today so we are also
trying to piece together this
three-dimensional puzzle of the past to
understand what it was that ancient
people were engaged with and what they
were experiencing in the ancient past
but now fortunately technology does
sometimes come to our assistance and we
can start to reconstruct what it is
that's happening in these ancient cities
in ways that make it more compelling for
visitors but then also help to remind us
as archaeologists what it is that
ancient people were living amongst they
were not living amongst bits and pieces
of broken architecture they were trying
to make their cities whole and vibrant
and dynamic just like we do today so
what I'd like to do is to think about
the ways in which there are three
components of urbanism that link the
past in the present the real building
blocks of urbanism are primarily people
places and the resultant possibilities
even though we might think that the
cities of the ancient world and the
cities of today must have been so very
different because we have electricity
and they didn't and we have bart and
they didn't what I can say is that in
those categories of people places and
possibilities modern and ancient cities
were exactly the same so there are a
number of ways that we can sort of peel
back those layers of time and think
about how urban continuities how the
idea of being an urban animal is
something that is now with us and is
going to be with us forever or at least
the next 10,000 years
so water what do modern and ancient
cities have in common first of all
there's monumental architects
that sense of people building things
that are much greater than what any
particular family would need or what any
community would need for any kind of
temporary purpose what we have is
monumental architecture that is often
functional sometimes entirely symbolic
like quite Tower or the Eiffel Tower or
any of those other kinds of towers but
it's the capacity to make and imagine
large-scale structures that really links
the past in the present another thing
that cities have in common all over the
world are divisions of labor so even
though we often think about Adam Smith
and The Wealth of Nations as describing
how it is that we can have more
efficient production processes by
dividing labor and having people
specialize in tasks this is something
that smart managers knew 6,000 years ago
as well we can see in the Roman world
that there were firings of kilns to
produce ceramic vessels twenty to
twenty-five thousand pieces at a time so
that's massive quantities of production
and consumption and also discard is
something that we can clearly see every
urban settlement past or present another
thing that we get in both modern and
ancient cities are the diverse economies
that characterize the migrations of
people coming in and the specialties of
different kinds of activities that
people are willing to take a chance on a
long time ago the archaeologist V Gordon
Child talked about how being in a city
was a godsend for somebody who was
manufacturing something like metal tools
that farmers might need only once or
twice a year so they couldn't keep
somebody like that in a village they had
to have this itinerant way of life until
cities came up and made it possible for
somebody to produce something very
utilitarian or even very esoteric and be
able to have customers every single day
coming to them so this is why
our places of innovation and when you
think about Fashion Week Fashion Week is
always in a city when you think about
tech innovations they're almost always
in cities so that that large number of
producers is met by a large number of
consumers we also get urban planning as
something that we find in every urban
settlement past and present and
oftentimes archeologists have looked
only at kind of the downtown areas of
ancient settlements where that sense of
planning is the most regularized we're
only now starting to look at some of the
outlying areas where planning is often
escaped by the people who live in them
so suburban areas and slum areas of
ancient cities are places where we can
see that the urban planning ethos is not
quite reached just as we have the same
concerns for our own growing cities both
here in the US and in other places as
well we get extensive hinterlands so
that the products that come into urban
settlements might come from an enormous
distance and yet as a consumer you know
that when you go to a market you will be
able to find what you need whether it's
an apple from Belgium or an apple from
New Zealand or an apple from Shasta
County you know as a consumer all these
pathways of transportation bring things
to you that you want and need from that
diverse and often distant hinterland and
finally it's the social networks that
make it possible for people in cities to
interact to interact with their
neighbors to interact with their friends
and also very importantly to interact
with strangers so now let's take a look
at each one of those things about the
people the places and the possibilities
and how it is that those in both modern
and ancient cities were able to come
together and exercise the kinds of
dynamic opportunities that they were
seeking that could be found in
other configuration of people other than
urbanism one of the things that we have
is people coming into cities for
religious purposes as well as from many
other kinds of activities now you might
remember that when we talked about early
ritual like Stonehenge or gobekli tepe
that those were only meant to be
temporary it doesn't mean that cities
are without religion in fact it's one of
the things that I think continually
surprises us about modern religious
movements is that we expect cities to be
secular but they are not you can check
this for yourself the next time you walk
down the street and look for all the
religious establishments that you are
customarily kind of overlooking you know
right down to the Jehovah's Witnesses on
the corner who are bringing a sort of
portable religion to the process of
urbanism but of course there are many
other things that happen in cities as
well when it comes to people and people
come to cities not only for a kind of
pilgrimage but also for education they
come for entertainment they come for
medical care when we think about the
cutting edge places of medical
innovation we think about cities because
cities are not only the places where
there is a big enough population that
some disease will eventually show up
unfortunately it's also where you get
the greatest number of medical
practitioners and of course people come
for employment and this is a huge draw
for cities you know despite the high
rents and other kinds of disadvantages
the reason that people come into cities
particularly young people is for these
opportunities of employment and
oftentimes when we think about
employment we're thinking about these
kinds of jobs we're thinking about
white-collar work or thinking about
office work we're thinking about tech
work especially here in the Bay Area but
we should also remember that the vast
majority of work that's to be had in
urban centers is
this kind of work it's the kind of work
that people have that they can do even
if they have no land in the countryside
if they have no skills and no education
and this is where a big proportion of
urban migration is happening not only
here in the US but in other parts of the
world as well where you've got people
who are coming in to be laborers to
build things to clean things to move
things to deal with food service and
that is also something that we can see
going back to the very earliest cities
where takeout food was part and parcel
of urban life right from the very
beginning all of those interactions
among people are of course done in
physical places and the places of cities
are things that kind of lock us into
streams of transportation of pathways of
movement of interaction but also of
regular occasions of meeting people
whether it's your favorite barista the
local coffee place all of those other
opportunities to not be a stranger in
the city that you're living in and in
ancient times as well the sense of
making places is something that was
critical to the integration of people
but also to the well-being of each and
every individual when we think about
those settlement dynamics we shouldn't
be thinking of big nonnamous groups but
we should be thinking about actual
people moving from one place to another
in the course of their everyday lives
and building things that were important
to them we can take an example of some
of the many religious edifices that we
see in ancient Mesopotamian cities such
as the city of aira do where you had the
beginnings of the city was also the
beginnings of anchoring people through
in Mesopotamia particularly religious
activities and so at the very bottom you
can imagine those long deep trenches of
excavations that would take years to get
down to the bottom of the beginnings of
the cities
and the beginning of the temple was very
modest it was something that just had a
few walls an altar and offering table
and then as the city became more
prosperous as the donors became more
prosperous then you would have growth so
we see a slightly later temple also at
the side of arrow do where you have the
same basic necessary components
you've got the offering table you've got
the altar but then you start to have
many many other kinds of configurations
you have rooms for the priestesses and
priests and then you have rooms where
you can store things and so on and then
as the city becomes quite wealthy as the
population base increases for devotions
to the temple then you start to get very
elaborate structures it's another way in
which we can see that dynamism of early
cities and the fact that they don't
stand still that they are constantly
under renovation under aggrandize mint
and under investment in ways that are of
course very familiar to us today as well
when we look at how all of those pieces
are put together such as this case the
site of subrata a roman site in libya
you can see how some of those really big
monumental structures like the giant
Halfmoon amphitheatre that you see here
are then surrounded by places of urban
planning where you've got a kind of a
downtown where you have monumental
architecture public buildings private
spaces and then connectivity that all
goes through those long straight roads
where you get a clear line of sight from
one area of residence to the next and
this is a kind of a typical
archeological excavation where you can
see and you know after many many years
of research that the main portions of
the site have been exposed and we can
get a sense of what the downtown was
like it's much less common to have
archaeologists also look at the
surrounding areas the kind of the
raggedy bits and the slums and empty
spaces of ancient settlements
because we just quite you know haven't
gotten there yet and also when you think
about you know empty spaces it would be
a little odd to write a grant to say
that you're not going to dig a temple or
a tomb or a fancy house but you want to
go and dig an empty space that hasn't
quite happened yet I think more typical
is this very unusual excavation of the
site of or also in Iraq where here you
can really see this kind of dense
neighborhood kinds of interaction where
the streets are not straight where
you've got houses that are all budding
one another you can imagine neighbors
and dogs and noise and cooking odors
wafting through in ways that really made
neighborhoods out of these places that
we excavate and find the foundations of
buildings if we imagine how it is that
people interacted in those spaces it
means that people are trying to live
their lives and change their
surroundings in order to suit the
configurations that they had of their
growing families or perhaps of their
shrinking families over time and there
are a couple of places in Mesopotamia
where there have been excavations of
these kinds of household areas where we
also have some written documents from
the very same households my colleague
Elizabeth stone has done some work
actually sort of comparing the wall
lines with the documents to show how it
is that these households have changed
over time in exactly the same way that
the big monumental architecture has also
changed and that sense of architecture
of placemaking and yet also being in the
same place is something that I think is
very nicely summed up in the work of
Jeremy Till who's an architectural
critic and architect himself who has
written very evocatively about how it is
that when we make something new in a
city we have to do it within the
footprint of something that is already
there he talks about the way that
architecture is
pendant on others at every stage of its
journey from initial sketch to
inhabitation and you can actually see it
when you go out in San Francisco or New
York Sydney or any of your other
favorite cities in the world and see how
it is that a place gets removed and
something else gets reimagined and put
in but it has to be in exactly that same
space that's true not only of modern
cities but ancient ones as well so this
is my picture of Rome in which in that
forum in that confusing forum there's
been this kind of stacking up of
architecture that just keeps getting
added on - right up to the 20th century
so all of those things come together to
be possibilities because if a city is
never finished then there's hope for
making things better than what we
inherited one of the most powerful
places in cities is not just the
monumental architecture but is the empty
spaces those places that archaeologists
are serving hesitant to write grants to
dig because empty spaces are extremely
flexible you know you can have a space
that is ostensibly for one purpose like
transportation become on other occasions
something altogether different like a
street that turns into a farmer's market
or
a Plaza that turns into a ceremonial
ground or an airport that becomes the
site of a demonstration that repurposing
of spaces of making empty spaces places
for that continual dynamism of the city
but on a moment's notice is something
that we also see both in historical and
ancient examples so that you have the
built architecture that we find
archaeologically
and then you have these open spaces for
which our imaginations and sometimes the
historical record also give us a glimpse
of the activities that are there so in
southern India a couple thousand years
ago there's some wonderful poetry about
what's happening in the streets that the
elephants are going through and clanging
their chains and the young women are
wearing their bangles and there's this
fragrant scent of rice that is
permeating the air so that it's these
open spaces that really help to convey
that dynamism of cities both past and
present
then there's infrastructure the idea
that not everything that is made is
something ceremonial or personal
sometimes it's practical and one of the
most amazing things about cities is the
amount and extent of infrastructure that
is necessary in order to make it
functional so underneath our feet are
all of the pipes and conduits for both
freshwater and dirty water exactly the
same kinds of separation of water that
we see in in Harappan Cities 4000 years
ago that we see in Japanese cities a
thousand years ago the idea that there
has to be something of what my colleague
is called an armature of the city to be
able to enable the city to function and
it's that infrastructure that's
underfoot that also gives the city and
opportunity to talk about to imagine to
envision to use that if then linguistic
construction that if we build it this
way a certain kind of thing will happen
so that is our transportation
infrastructure that is our reimagining
of highways railways turning into
pathways it's the idea that a fixed
location a kind of architectural
dependency does not mean that we stop
imagining how things could be made
better
in cities there is always mother nature
as well so our infrastructure is not
just according to our wishes of what we
think should happen to the armature of
the city but also the things that we
have to deal with that mother nature has
always been there for us so things like
floods and earthquakes and other kinds
of natural phenomena are always part of
cities as well and in the archaeological
record of ancient China in particular we
can see this tremendous attention to
detail in which there are records of
flooding over the last 2,000 years in
which practically every year there's a
flood so urban planners and urban
managers have used infrastructure not
only to imagine possibilities of
connecting through things like bridges
but also the necessity of managing
against the kinds of sometimes unwanted
natural phenomena that are also part of
cities and so that's also contributing
to the dynamism of cities the idea that
you've got a perpetual need to upgrade
and maintain so whether it's pseudo or
modern London the idea of the natural
world is always there but it's hard to
get people excited about infrastructure
because infrastructure requires
maintenance and people definitely don't
like maintenance as humans we are
historically biased against maintenance
and yet that's exactly what
infrastructure needs and is something
that is always part of the dialogue of
infrastructure that when we need to
build new things we can't just think
about building the new thing but also
maintaining the thing that we've already
got and I think we have to get used to
the idea that maintenance is not only as
expensive as new architecture it's
probably more expensive so can we get
people to be more excited about
infrastructure
it happened in Paris in the 19th century
when the Paris sewers were put in they
were a focus of public commentary and
you know a desire to experience
something that was at the time
altogether new and so you know you
actually had people taking tours of the
infrastructure and being very excited
about it so maybe it's just a question
of rebranding right
maybe we shouldn't think about this as
you know infrastructure or the Paris
sewers we just call it the tunnel of
love and that's proof that maybe we can
be excited about infrastructure sure we
can so that not only has this become a
symbol of the city but it's something
that undergoes a very willing form of
maintenance so somewhere between five to
ten thousand gallons of paint a year and
30 painters are dedicated to keeping the
Golden Gate Bridge golden an
infrastructure is also a way for public
officials to perform visibility so this
is a street in Tokyo where a very minor
repair seems to require a great deal of
performativity including uniforms and
you know somebody at attention so it's
not just about the thing that's being
maintained or repaired but a
demonstration of good governance that
somebody is paying attention to this
infrastructure the same thing is true of
those kinds of cleaners and street
sweepers that are often supported not
only by individual cities but also by
Business Improvement Districts and so
that you have various parts of cities
they're not only here in San Francisco
but in practically every major city of
the world now you have people in a
uniform of the business district of that
portion of the city very visibly
engaging in things like maintenance
infrastructure is also a way
advising people of recommending of
codifying the language the social
networks in a way that suggests
something that is both you know good for
your health but also that somebody is
kind of watching over the process that
it's not just a free-for-all of
connectivity but a certain structured
way of movement that is actually meant
to help things work better so people who
are parking engineers are constantly
tinkering with the idea of how to make
city streets flow better how to make
traffic move more efficiently or adding
or taking away bus lanes and bike lanes
and so on and at the same time putting
in some instructions for you the end
user so you have to go and they look
very carefully at all of the different
thou shalt nots whenever it is you're
trying to park someplace or giving you
helpful instructions about how to cross
street or even using the most basic
infrastructure is a kind of branding oh
that can't be right everybody knows that
la doesn't have in water
there we go so that sense of the built
environment no matter how small or the
thing that you passed that you tread
underfoot is part of that urban sense of
belonging that helps to link us all as
strangers that helps to make urban
centers thrive that each individual can
contribute to and nowhere is that more
evident than under circumstances where
people work together in order to
overcome something that mother nature or
other people have done to interrupt the
life of the city and that hashtag your
name of city here strong is something
that we're starting to see over and over
and over again and is actually being
thought of by people as a way of making
a commitment to their neighbors in a
spontaneous way at times of need that
sense of spontaneous collectivity is now
being brought into the community in a
more organized level not just to respond
to disasters when they occur but to
proactively become engaged in being
ready for the next one so this is what
we have in Los Angeles now this is a
website and a whole concept with the
acronym Rylan ready your la neighborhood
and it's very clear on the website the
kind of necessity of preparation for all
of us not only for ourselves but for
each other that disasters can overwhelm
the capacity of 911 Abers those people
you used to call strangers become your
best source of help I want to close this
part of the conversation by going to two
quotes that I think exemplify this sense
of dynamic community the sense of
continuity that we see in cities the way
in which having started cities about
6,000 years ago
there is no way we can go back with all
of their deficits cities are the best
places for human communities to be able
to move forward with the things that we
want out of life the first quote is from
Stuart Brown and this sense of promise
but also fidelity and commitment is
something that comes through in these
words a realm of intimate personal power
is developing power of the individual to
conduct their own education find their
own inspiration shape their own
environment and share their adventure
with whoever is interested the next
quote is in homage to the wonderful
venue that we find ourselves in this
evening a San Francisco jazz center the
most important thing is the spirit of
jazz which is about freedom about
improvisation about courage I think if
we substitute the word cities for the
word jazz then I think my job here this
evening is done thank you
[Applause]
I was interested to see at the beginning
of the acknowledgments of your book you
began by saying we were surprised by how
much fun this book was to write what's
that about you know as a writer if I
don't write every day I get grouchy
actually a day without writing would be
like a day without breathing and there
is something amazing about the way that
words work they are the most powerful
tool that humans have and the idea of
being able to put together and describe
what it's like to be on an
archaeological site or to run a dig or
to work with students and then be able
to put that on a page how could that not
be fun mm-hmm so we got a question from
Linda Morris saying that cities that are
losing population like Detroit and Peter
Schwartz mentions you grew up in Camden
New Jersey which is a city that is at
times half dead and there's the Chinese
cities the coastal called your ghost
cities they're built basically without
people at least for quite a while cities
without people what happens there so the
Chinese cities case is actually quite
interesting because many of the
metropolitan areas have become extremely
crowded and the idea of the Chinese
government has to try to bud off some of
these population centers and build
entirely new cities under the idea of if
you build it they will come and people
are buying flats in those cities but
they're not living there yet there are a
lot of flats that are unoccupied but I
think that they will eventually be
occupied and the idea is that they're
not full of people I say they're not
full of people yet mm-hmm although
historically there are other cases
archaeologically where rulers have put
together cities
and you know people stayed there for the
rulers lifetime and then as soon as the
ruler passed away everybody just you
know turned around and left their cities
like that in India there are cities like
that in Egypt like Amarna the idea of
this command city is not always enough
to make it work there's new capitals in
different many post-colonial Nations put
up a new capital some of those are
thriving others of them are are not
they're almost the only kind of city I
know that actually dies or the dynastic
cities where we're gonna have the
capital of our dynasty here and
everybody has to leave they say it's a
command situation and often they're not
in a convenient place like on a coast or
someone in in in a land like Brasilia
and those seem to be the only sort of
built in temporary cities are the ones
that they of course the builders imagine
this is my legacy forever but is the
opposite yes and there are other kinds
of places that function like cities that
are not quite built up and these are
some of the very massive refugee camps
that are also laid out in these very
regular kinds of ways and then around
the edges there's this the less
organized kinds of settlements as new
people are coming in and so on
I think there's some great studies to be
done on those to see how it is that you
have a kind of an instant City actually
that's right there's lots of studies on
slums which are incredibly dynamic and
important you've spent time in India and
see what it's like in Mumbai ER and so
on one thing I have read about ghost
cities and there's actually a book
called ghost cities about their Chinese
ghost cities and they are they sort of
perform the function like the slums of
India in a sense except that the
infrastructure and the apparatus and all
this stuff is there and then there's
gradually infill and there's lots of
people in China's lots of people moving
to opportunity urban type opportunities
and so these ghost cities that are
shocking when you see them their first
del everything's new but there's nobody
there later on there's people there and
so you know
it starts out as a kind of a real estate
scam and then becomes a real city anyway
see what I thought again is that cities
find a way one way or another the urban
thing is gonna happen is that your sense
I would say that it's people who find a
way okay people who find an opportunity
and when you think about cities as
places of people there's of course
there's the white-collar employment and
there's the blue-collar employment but
there's other things that pull cities
together as well and other things that
people come to cities for and one of the
things that happen in cities is of
course crime because that's where the
money is so that's why you have crime in
cities but also more sobering ly this is
why homelessness is an urban problem
because that's where people can manage
to survive even if they have absolutely
no other resources so you know you don't
think of homelessness as a rural problem
it is an urban problem for precisely
that same reason question on climate
change from Jack house so a lot of
cities are coastal a lot of cities are
on coasts that are not steep like San
Francisco or Seattle there on the coasts
that are pretty flat already especially
in the developing world and the sense we
had the previous speaker Jeff Goodell
name of his talk is the water will come
and the water is already coming gonna
keep coming he's gonna keep coming
faster it's not gonna stop coming how do
these coastal cities and river cities do
you think I wasn't going to play out for
them so the climate is not changing only
right now the climate has always been
changing right so ever since the
beginning of the Holocene ten to twelve
thousand years ago the water level has
been rising the thing that's different
about now is that the water level is
rising more rapidly than it has in the
prior of ten to twelve thousand years so
the projection of rising water would be
the case anyway if the Holocene was on
its regular trajectory what's happening
is that now practically within our life
we're going to be able to see the upward
tick of that effect and yet flooding is
something that cities have always had to
deal with and when you think about
coastal cities if you remember that map
that showed where all the biggest cities
are many of them are in coastal places
where they have always been beset by
typhoons and hurricanes and tidal waves
so that we should think about flooding
as a kind of regular long-term
experience the only thing that's
different is that the rate of flooding
will increase and the frequency of
flooding will increase so every since
been working on an academic paper on
urban flooding and appealing through
archaeological site reports to look at
evidence for flood deposits and things
like that and so that the paper is
provisionally titled urban flooding is
normal I'm having trouble getting a
traction with that people want to think
that every kind of disaster must be new
to the 21st century it is either you
know comforting or you know shoulder
shrugging to think that it's always been
there you've done a lot of archaeology
around the Mediterranean and there are
parts of the Mediterranean where you
have to dive to do the dig and nobody
lives there now
see a little bit about how that played
out and what kind of you know what was
the timeframe of these things going
underwater and just what is it when a
city actually drowns alright so the
Roman world is one of the very best
places to be able to think about ancient
cities because there were so many of
them and there's been so much
archaeology in the Mediterranean region
and so some of the kinds of things that
we think about like tectonics are things
that Roman cities very much had to deal
with I have a colleague Jordan Pickett
who is working on the effect of
earthquakes and basically earthquakes
were a godsend to ancient Roman urban
planners because when the earthquake
came then they could get rid of that you
know old temple or administrative
building or whatever it was so the idea
of never waste a good crisis is not new
so the Romans were also practicing this
and and they could also see the rather
slow changes you know aggradation and
you know tectonic shifts and so on and
there are harbours in the roman
mediterranean multiple sites where a
harbor of the first century BC a hundred
years later would be completely useless
they'd have to move the harbour or
they'd have to you know create a new one
so people responding to mother nature in
that dynamic way is also not new we can
actually see it in the archaeological
record interesting thing that emerged
from Jeff gazelles talk which shocked me
is that he you might imagine spent a
fair amount of time in Florida and New
Jersey looking at the places where
they're already getting what they call
sunlight flooding basically a king tide
that fills the street and then fills the
yard and sometimes fills the basement
and he's going and talking to people who
experience that and asking are you know
are you gonna move no this is my home
and I thought that denial would be a
sort of climate change denial would be
at the lowest among people most impacted
but in fact it's quite high
along people most impacted is that some
kind of urban phenomenon that you know
here in the city we can do anything we
want well you know there is that's that
can-do sense of optimism in in urban
places that the idea that people will
will overcome that's what the hashtag
you know name of city is strong is about
is that regardless of how awful the
circumstance is that people pull
together city strong is go ahead and
have your climate change we're just
gonna keep elevating Houston until you
know building a tell is something that
worked for ancient people you know they
were always trying to build a little
higher than somebody else
I've seen I've seen the future and it's
a weird combination of denial and
innovation and everything's gonna depend
on patient the other great thing we keep
learning about cities you point out
Jeffrey west points out in his book
scale the cities are about moving fast
and as you say or we changed the
material of cities very rapidly compared
to non cities and so I guess we'll just
keep building ahead or whatever happens
that's what you're saying yes and in
terms of you know private homes not
having a basement is important of course
you cannot do that with a transportation
system that's underground and so you
know the kind of scale that works at the
individual scale it's not something that
works at the larger urban planning scale
which means that you need overarching
civic thoughtfulness about how to design
systems that take into account these
different kinds of natural or
anthropologically anthropogenically
accelerated natural events one of the
things he made about the Fertile
Crescent or the original since the first
cities took shape is later referred to
as the fragile Crescent because
basically climate and stability in that
area and how does the fragile Crescent
play out in terms of cities so the idea
of you know we all grew up with the
Mesopotamia is the the Fertile Crescent
hilly flanks to the Fertile Crescent
which made it sound like it was this
ideal place for a cities to come up and
then all the archaeologists who went to
work there and said oh god it's really
hot and it's like it's drought the
farmers keep losing their crops and it
burns and so on this is not fertile this
is awful so it's an archaeologist Tony
Wilkinson and his group who came up with
the idea with a fragile Crescent oh now
that's really interesting because it
suggests that cities come up not in
places that are really wonderful but in
cities in places that have some kind of
problem right so immediately you think
of something like New Orleans right New
Orleans probably really ought not to
still exist
but people just keep going back and
mopping it up because it has something
that overcomes that liability
so maybe cities thrive and survive
because they are inherently dependent on
creativity to exist at all I think
that's a really wild idea you know that
that synergy of creativity is what makes
cities persist if you think about in the
last thousand years there is not a
single city that has been abandoned
except for maybe Chernobyl right in that
hmm for a while there is that sort of
theory of hydraulic civilizations where
you know controlled flooding like in
Egypt or managing with canals and
managing of water provision for the
Middle Eastern cities for places like in
Cambodia where do you buy into the
hydraulic theory of civilization well
you know water and culture go together
they have to because without water
people can't live without water people
can't do agriculture and its really
maddening actually to get it the what
came first right because you've got to
dig down through all these levels and
then hope that you hit the one spot that
happened to be the earliest spot of a
certain thing so there's also an idea
that you know cities came first and then
domestication came afterward that's an
old idea that Jane Jacobs had that has
been thoroughly dismantled by
archeologists okay but there's a kernel
of truth in the sense that cities
accelerate the production of Agriculture
in hinterlands because nobody's gonna
grow green very few people are gonna
attend animals in a city you have to
depend on that outlying hinterlands but
those people in rural places have to
simultaneously ramp up production to
satisfy the urban market and watch their
kids leave to go to the city so there's
this thing happen
in rural places that we certainly see in
the modern world especially in you know
many developing countries where this
happens in India a great deal we live in
a village where we're working and yet
you see nobody between the ages of about
ten and sixty because all of the people
are working in cities that has to have
been the same in ancient cities as well
as so people in rural areas had to ramp
up to produce innovate in terms of
production if some of that innovation
also involved making canals and
irrigation reservoirs then that was in
response to the city even though the
domesticated plants and animals long
predated urban life seeing more about
Indian cities you've done some
archeology there as I understand it and
most of us are not you know sort of
familiar with them you kept in the mid
East and so on but the whole Indian
early civilization is untold story what
do you find in cities there so there are
really two periods of urbanization in
ancient India one of them was the Bronze
Age Harappan culture from about 2500 BC
to about 1900 BC and there was a handful
of cities Harappa mohenjo-daro you might
have heard of up and down the area of
what's now Pakistan in western India and
also along the river so you know yes
along the Indus River but then also
Dholavira which is a site in India was
right on the ocean like on the run of
catch a big bay and those cities
survived and thrived for about six
hundred years and then they sort of
disintegrated about a thousand years
later the idea of urbanism came back do
we know why they disintegrate it seems
to be a one-two punch that's the thing
that seems to get ancient cities is that
it's you know some tectonic uplift and
some migration that kind of overwhelms
cities but the Indus case is quite odd
because the number of cities is
relatively low I think maybe the urban
network was not strong enough to be
absorbing moving populations possibly
say more about urban network
for America that's what you see starting
around the sixth century BC so after
about a thousand years of not having
anything that looked like cities in the
Indian subcontinent all of a sudden all
up and down the Ganges all throughout
the Peninsular subcontinent you get
cities and you get a lot of them there's
probably about a hundred settlements
that we can say archaeologically our
cities and this is also the time of
beginning of buddhism and jainism it's a
time when there's a lot of movement of
people for pilgrimage and migration into
cities and that is a thriving urban
network and it continues right to the
present day and I suppose one of the
things that's different now is it used
to be that urban networks were regional
and you talk about the Pacific Rim as if
it's a region now let's know basically
half the planet you're talking about so
it looks like network of cities is what
totally global now or up and there's the
talk of global cities and you know
there's a certain finance financial
levels in the sectional way in a global
economies the global cities is that your
sense of things I think so I mean when
you travel to other cities you you know
you come into a new city even if it's a
place or a country that you've never
been before you see many of the same
things you go from the airport you go
through some suburbs
you see high-rises downtown with glass
fronts you've seen some areas of very
wealthy housing you see some areas of
slums you see all kinds of different
jobs that people are doing and so on you
almost have to like rub your eyes and
say oh wait where am i again if you
travel a lot it's a common phenomenon
wait which which city am I in right now
it's a Bangkok Singapore is it you know
Johannesburg is it London you know that
is a kind of globalism that is I think
driven by a sense of dynamism that is
more than just national it's it's
international well one of the things you
point out is that I referred to a
nation's come and go and
persevere and you may prefer the point
it almost doesn't matter what nation a
city is in it's just gonna keep growing
what's that about so cities have been
extremely resilient over time and we
worry about cities being vulnerable or
fragile but actually cities are highly
sustainable in the sense that they can
always work their way out of a problem
and it's like having you know your
markets of food if you can't get apples
from Belgium they come in from New
Zealand you know there's a way that
cities reach out into these country
sides and bring things together but
they're also resilient because of those
networks that they sustain amongst
themselves with some exceptions
now you can never discount the leverage
of the nation-state which is what keeps
New Orleans alive right if it weren't
for the feds pumping in lots of money
because cities are too big to fail then
you you might get an abandonment of
someplace like New Orleans hmm
interesting question from Julie Anderson
please explain Phoenix please
there's that there's that sustainability
thing not in not in the sense that we
often think about it as you know
sustainability means being able to plan
for a future where everybody gets what
they need and so on but sustainability
in the sense that Phoenix is just
sucking up all the resources that it
possibly can and it's drawing from an
enormous hinterland you know just like
Los Angeles is drawing its water from
the Sierras and from you sorry
Phoenix is drawing water from from all
of us and it started with an idea and it
just keeps going because it draws more
people in and the resources follow and
the technology follows and people go to
Phoenix for education and for
entertainment and for employment and for
medical care for all those other kinds
of things and it just it just becomes
this upward spiral of growth against all
common sense one suppose there's your
answer
Phoenix makes no sense but that a city
becomes its own reason and that this is
sort of maybe the best argument I've
heard for space colonies or even
something on Mars is that once you've
got a city it's smart enough and busy
enough and energetic enough and able to
draw on some kind of hinterland effects
enough they don't keep itself going no
matter what yes I mean if you look at
cities in places that are otherwise
failed States you know a city like
Kinshasa is growing and growing even
though there is not a successful
national integration you find cities
like this in other parts of the world as
well where the state is function you
know absent or dysfunctional but City is
there and it's because of those people
they come in because they have nothing
in the countryside and maybe they can
get something in the city and maybe
that's you know small-scale employment
you hear in a lot of places where
someone who's qualified to be a
schoolteacher or medical doctor migrates
and they
I'm a street sweeper they work in an
office because it's better than the
alternative which is nothing which then
raises the question of a city that is
the city state that manages without our
nation wrapped around it is a nation
Singapore venez venez prospered in a
chaotic Europe for 800 years and
Singapore looks incredibly stable
incredibly inventive cut itself off
basically from the nation of Malaysia
and became its own nation is that the
way to be a prospering city now let's
just get rid of the nation around you
there are many ways to be a prospering
city it helps to be on a coaster it
helps to be right if you remember the
map of all the the cities think about
the coastal cities you know coasts are
the place where the majority of urban
residents look hence the water problem
hence the the flooding problem but those
that's because of shipping yes it's
because of being able to these coastal
cities or coastal cities and River
Cities because ships could come and go
to those places yeah still the case that
shipping is the cheapest form of
transportation you know in Asia old
technology for thousands of years and we
are still totally dependent on it so
once you have been shipping and you
against cities you're gonna have them
that's what I hear and then if you can
add travel through the air jet airplanes
and so on and travel through the you
know the InfoSphere and so on all of
these just add to cities they're just
other ways to basically have these be
centers of of transport and trade and
economic activity exactly and even in
the modern world where we think that
perhaps we could get rid of cities or
have an alternative through tech right
so the idea of being able to work from
anyplace it's very interesting to think
about where tech companies want to be
you know they they don't want to be out
in the middle of
some place even though they could if
they want to be in San Francisco they
want to be in Seattle they want to be in
those places where their employees can
access the education the entertainment
the employment the other opportunities
that go along with being a city so
Geoffrey West when you talk about cities
getting faster and that they're they
create problems but they're so
innovative they can solve problems
faster than they create them and they
then solve problems for in a sense
everybody it's part of what you ask
cities to do and he says but this
obviously can't go on forever so you
just can't keep on growing even though
they get better and faster and more
prosperous the bigger they get they've
got to stop somewhere and I say okay
what's your data on that and it doesn't
exist yet do you think cities will just
keep growing because of these advantages
there doesn't seem to be a natural
upward stopping point for urbanism in
fact one of the things it's really
interesting is that it was said
relatively recently that half of the
world's population is living in cities
and I just looked up some new data and
it's 55 percent now so you know where
the trend is going right toward 80
percent people think because some of the
nations that are already sort of
saturated like I think you said that
Britain 92 percent urban or something
like that and much of Latin America
actually for a very long time it's been
about 80 percent urban which itself is
an anomaly that one wants to find out
more about nevertheless it looks like
it's not only urbanity forever but it's
urbanity more and more and more powerful
does that live off some point you thank
her what are we looking at there's
always going to be a rural component you
know urban centers and rural places need
each other I think that's an important
thing to to think about in current
parlance but the proportion of people
living in cities is likely to increase
and the idea of creating new
not only the city's we already have the
four thousand then we already have on
the planet but I was recently reading a
very interesting assessment of Addis
Ababa Ethiopia
apparently the Ethiopian government has
proposed a hundred new cities for
Ethiopia so it means that the idea of
creating urban places it's not something
that's just being left to happenstance
or you know individual communities and
desires and things like that but viewing
urbanism as a positive momentum for
national growth and identity I think is
really an amazing you think we're paying
attention to Chinese and there's China
is building cities on purpose more than
anybody and it sounds like you're
suggesting some other developing
countries are saying okay that's the way
to do things we'll leave that to you is
that you think what's happening it's
certainly possible I mean urbanism is a
very desirable middle-class affirming
kind of structure and one of the things
I talk about in the book is that
urbanism in the middle class grew up
together before you had cities you
didn't need middle managers you didn't
need accountants you didn't need people
to keep track of laborers but when you
started to have larger and larger
enterprises in cities then you needed
someone to keep track of all that stuff
those people needed education the
education is often signaled by
credentials like diplomas and so that's
how urban ISM education the middle class
production consumption all kind of gets
tied together in the same you know
physical package so it looks like
language was before cities but writing
and accounting and then eventually money
or the city creations yes yes exactly
so the first writing comes along in
Mesopotamia shortly after the beginnings
of cities the first money is really
interesting because there were perfectly
viable cities all over the world without
coined money money is actually a very
late invention so you know a very
sophisticated barter system kind of
expectations that social network
that had to do with money and not just
conversation is something that also goes
way back and urbanism
so you wrote your city's book you still
do archeology or you mainly a writer now
oh my goodness I still do archaeology I
was in the field in January and February
with my Indian colleagues looking at
actually hinterland settlement we've
been very fortunate that my colleague RK
mohanty and I started with the big urban
center and we've sort of been working
our way backwards oftentimes what
happens archaeologists start working at
small centers and they think that
someday they might get a chance to work
in the big city we were extremely lucky
and being able to start with the big
city first and we've worked our way
backwards and in looking at smaller
settlements and town sized sites we
really see that that pull of the urban
center because when we were excavating
at the city of Chicago we would find
lots of the you know consumer trinkets
and lots and lots of trash and things
like that and then out in the rural
settlements you know there was much less
of that excess and abundance of
consumerism and you just got the sense
that the young people especially you
know as soon as the big city came up
with it's big fortification wall and
monumental architecture and everything I
think the kids just left the farm and
went that was it so the kids and one of
the things that fascinates me about the
Mid East is you have these tells these
mountains basically that with the city
on top that the mountain was made by the
city's trash accumulating and and you
know the old mud brick place is kind of
decaying skirt just bill another buck
took place on top of it and that becomes
part of the heal that mode of city
building then the water has to go uphill
toward money as usual I actually play
out and should it play out more now that
we're trying to stay out of flooding you
know it's a very low-tech solution you
know building higher means that you're
up out of the water and sometimes it
doesn't take very much if you're talking
about you know tidal fluctuations you're
putting a building on a plinth is an
age-old architectural solution that we
see over and over again in different
parts of the world so it does work just
keep layering up ahead of the water
that's right I like that let's call out
a night take you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]